[Musique]
tu n'es plus robin de locksley tué robin
des bois
tu étais un homme est à présent qui fait
de venir à voir
il je vais te montrer comment
cite moi je t'en prie
il faut que tu sois un guerrier le but
de cassard
qu'est ce que tu fais avec mon mentor
encore quand est-ce que je commence
enfin à voler quoi
c'est tout ce que tu as il ya des bruits
qui courent
sur un voleur je fais respecter la loi
je veux qu'on me rapporte tout ce qui
est dit sur ce voleur
il n'y a qu'une chose qui le
maintiennent au pouvoir l'argent on va
le volet je veux voler le trésor du
royaume organise une réunion avec tous
ceux qui sont avec nous c'est notre
chance voilà le plan tu va agir de
l'intérieur tuer un homme
rapprochez toit du shérif vous savez qui
est ce voleur
apparemment quelqu'un de bien entraîné
et que le combat n'effraie pas vous
finirez par l'avoir
notre plan fonctionne
va mordre à l'appât
je vais leur rappeler qu'ils ne sont pas
le peuple mais ils sont mais sujet
c'est dû
je suicide
d'abord parce que
vous êtes un modèle pour le peuple
face à lui qui veulent vivre à saint
paulin
on est tous super maintenant si on se
fait prendre il ne tueront tous
c'est très motivant merci je n'ai plus
robin de loxley
et robin des bois